The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PATRICK HENRY WINSTON:
Oh, how to start.
I have been on the Navy Science
Board for a couple of decades.
And so as a consequence,
I've had an opportunity
to spend two weeks for a
couple of decades in San Diego.
And the first thing I do
when I get to San Diego
is I go to the zoo, and
I look at the orangutans
and ask myself, how come I'm
out here and they're in there?
How come you're not all covered
with orange hair instead
of hardly any hair at all?
Well, my answer to that is that
we can tell stories and they
can't.
So this is the
center of my talk.
That's what I have come to
believe after a long time.
So I'm going to be
talking about stories
and to give you a
preview of where
I'm going to go with this,
I like to just show you
some of the questions
that I propose to address
in the course of the next hour.
I want to start talking
about this by way of history.
I've been in
artificial intelligence
almost since the
beginning, and so
I was a student
of Marvin Minsky,
and it's interesting that the
field started a long time ago--
55 years ago-- with perhaps
the most important paper
in the field, Steps Toward
Artificial Intelligence.
It was about that time that
the first intelligent program
was written.
It was a program that
could do calculus problems
as well as an MIT freshman--
a very good MIT freshman.
That was done in 1961.
And those programs led to a half
century of enormous progress
in the field.
All sorts of ideas and
subfields like machine learning
were spawned.
Useful applications.
But as you know, there's
been an explosion
in these useful applications
in recent years.
I've stolen this
slide from Tomaso
but I added a couple of
things that I particularly
think are of special
importance like Echo.
You all know about Amazon
Echo, of course, right?
I swear, it astonishes me.
Many people don't know
about Amazon Echo.
It's Siri in a beer can.
It's a Siri that you can
talk to across the room
and say how long should
I boil a hard boiled egg
or I've fallen down.
Please call for an ambulance.
So it's a wonderful thing.
I think most people
don't know about it
because of privacy concerns.
Having something listening to
you all the time in your home
may not be the most
comfortable kind of thing.
But anyhow, it's there.
So this has caused quite a
lot of interest in the field
lately.
Boris has just talked
about Siri and Jeopardy,
but maybe the thing that's
astonished the world the most
is this captioning program
I think you've probably seen
before the last week or two.
And man, I don't know
what to think of this.
I don't know why it's
created such a stir,
except that that
caption makes it
look like that system knows a
lot that it doesn't actually
know.
First of all, it's
trained on still photos.
So it doesn't know about motion.
It doesn't know about play.
It doesn't know what
it means to be young.
It would probably
say the same thing
if we replaced those
faces with geriatrics.
Yet when we see that, we
presume that it knows a lot.
It's sort of
parasitic semantics.
The intelligence is coming
from our interpretation
of the sentence, not from
it producing the sentence.
So yeah, it's a great
engineering achievement,
but it's not as
smart as it looks.
And of course, as
you know, there's
been a whole industry
of fooling papers.
Here's a fooling example.
One of those is considered
by a standard deep neural net
to be a school bus,
and the other is not
considered to be a school bus.
And just a few pixels
have been changed.
Imperceptible to us.
It still looks like a school bus
but not to the deep neural net.
And of course, these things
are considered school buses
in another fooling paper.
Why in the world would those
be considered school buses?
Presumably because of
some sharing of texture.
Well, anyhow, people
have gotten all excited
and especially Elon Musk
has gotten all excited.
We are summoning the demon.
So Musk said that in
an off-the-cuff answer
to a question at the, let's
see, an anniversary of the MIT
AeroAstro Department.
Someone asked him if he
was interested in AI,
and that's his
off-the-cuff response.
So it's interesting
that those of us
who've been around for a while
find this beyond interesting.
It's curious, because a
long time ago philosophers
like Hubert Dreyfus were saying
that it was not possible.
And so now we've shifted from
not possible to the scariest
thing imaginable.
We can't stop ourselves
from chuckling.
Well, Dreyfus must
know that he's wrong,
but maybe he's right too.
What we really had to wait for
for all of these achievements
was massive amounts
of computing.
So I'd like to go a little
further back in history
while I'm talking about
history, and the next thing back
there is 65 years ago Turing's
paper on machine intelligence.
It's interesting that that paper
is widely assumed to be about
the Turing test and it isn't.
If you look at the actual
paper content, what you find
is that only a couple of pages
were devoted to the test.
Most of it was
devoted to discussion
of arguments for and
against the possibility
of artificial intelligence.
I've read that paper 20
times, because I prescribe it
in my course, so I have
to read it every year.
And every time I read it,
I become more convinced
that what Turing
was talking about
is arguments against
AI, not about the tests.
So why the test?
Well, he's a mathematician
and a philosopher.
And no mathematician
or philosopher
would write a paper without
defining their terms.
So he squeezed into
some kind of definition.
Counterarguments took
up a lot of space,
but they didn't have to.
If Turing had taken
Marvin Minsky's course
in the last couple
of years, he wouldn't
have bothered with that test,
because Minsky introduced
the notion of a suitcase word.
That's a word--
he likes that term
because what he means by
that is that the word is
so big, like a big suitcase,
you can stuff anything into it.
So for me, this has been a great
thought because, if you ask me,
is Watson intelligent?
Is the Jeopardy-playing
system intelligent?
My immediate response is, sure.
It has a kind of intelligence.
As Boris points out, it's not
every kind of intelligence,
and it doesn't think
like we do, and there
are some kinds of
thinking that it doesn't
do that we do quite handily.
But it's silly to argue about
whether it's intelligent
or not.
It has aspects, some
kinds of intelligence.
So what Turing really
did was establish
that this is something that
serious people can think about
and suggests that there's
no reason to believe
that it won't happen someday.
And he centered that whole paper
on these kind of arguments,
to the arguments against AI.
It's fun to talk about those.
Each of them deserves attention.
I'll just say a word or two
about number four there,
Lady Lovelace's objection.
She was, as you all know,
the sponsor and programmer
of Charles Babbage when he
attempted to make a computer
mechanically.
And what she said,
she was obviously
pestered with the same kind
of things that everybody in AI
is always pestered with.
And at one point, she was
reported to have said--
let me put it in my patois.
Don't worry about a thing.
They can only do what
they're programmed to do.
And of course, what
she should have said
is that they can only do what
they've been programmed to do
and what we've taught them
to do and what they've
learned how to do on their own.
But maybe that wouldn't
have had the soothing effect
she was looking for.
In any event, this is when
people started thinking about
whether computers could think.
But it's not the first time
people thought about thinking,
that we have to go back 2,400
years or so to get to that.
And when we do, we think about
Plato's most famous work,
The Republic, which
was clearly a metaphor
to what goes on in our brains
and our minds and our thinking.
He couched it in
terms of a metaphor
with how a state is
organized with philosopher
kings and merchants
and soldiers and stuff.
But he was clearly
talking about a kind
of theory of brain-mind
thinking that
suggested there are
agents in there that are
kind of all working together.
But it's important
to note, I think,
that The Republic is a good
translation of the Latin de re
publica, which is
a bad translation
of the Greek politeia.
And politeia, interestingly,
is a Greek word
that my Greek friends
tell me is untranslatable.
But it means something
like a society or community
or something like that.
And the book was about the mind.
So Plato-- it could
have been translated
as the society of
mind, in which case
it would have anticipated
Marvin Minsky's
book with the same
title by 2,400 years.
Well, maybe that was
not the first time
that humans thought
about thinking,
but it was an early landmark.
And now it's, I think,
useful to go back to when
humans started thinking.
And that takes us back
about 50,000 years--
not millions of years--
a few tens of
thousands of years.
So it probably happened
in southern Africa.
It was probably 60,000
or 70,000 years ago
that it started happening.
It probably happened in
the neck-down population,
because if the
population is too big,
an innovation can't take hold.
It was about that
time that people--
us, we-- started drilling
holes in sea shells,
presumably for making jewelry.
And then it wasn't
long after that
that we departed from those
Neanderthal guys in a big way.
And we started painting
caves like the ones
at Lascaux, carving figurines
like the one at Brassempouy.
And I think the most important
question we can ask in AI
is what makes us different
from that Neanderthal who
couldn't do these things?
See, that's not the
question that Turing asked.
The question Turing
asked was how can we
make a computer reason?
Because as a
mathematician, he thought
that was a kind of supreme
capability of human thinking.
And so for 20, 30
years, AI people
focused on reasoning
as the center of AI.
And what they should
have been asking is,
what makes us different from
the Neanderthals and chimpanzees
and other species?
It creates a different
research agenda.
Well, I'm much influenced by
the paleoanthropologist, Ian
Tattersall, who writes
extensively about this
and says that it
didn't evolve, it
was more of a discovery
than an evolution.
Our brains came to be
what they are for reasons
other than human intelligence.
So he thinks of it
as a minor change
or even a discovery of
something we didn't know we had.
In any event, he talks
about becoming symbolic.
But of course, as a
paleoanthropologist
and not a computationalist,
he doesn't
have the vocabulary
for talking about that
in computational terms.
So you have to go to
someone like Noam Chomsky
to get a more computational
perspective on this.
And what Chomsky says is that--
who is also, by the way,
a fan of Tattersall--
what Chomsky says is
that what happened
is that we acquired the
ability to take two concepts
and put them together
and make a third concept
and do that without limit.
An AI person would say,
oh, Chomsky's talking
about semantic nets.
A linguist would
say he's talking
about the merge operation.
But it's the same thing.
As an aside, I'll tell you that
a very important book will come
out in January, I think,
by Berwick and Chomsky
and addresses two questions--
why do we have any language and
why do we have more than one?
You know, when you think
about it, it's weird.
Why should we have a language
and now that we have one,
why should we all
have different ones?
And their answer is roughly
that this innovation
made language possible.
But once you've
got the competence,
it can manifest itself in
many engineering solutions.
They also talk a
lot about how we're
different from other
species, and they
like to talk about the
fact that we can think
about stuff that isn't there.
So we can think about
apples even when
we're not looking at an apple.
But back to the main line,
when Spelke talked to you,
she didn't talk
to you about what
I consider to be the
greatest experiment
in developmental
psychology ever,
even though it wasn't
necessarily-- well,
I confused myself.
Let me tell you
about the experiment.
Spelke doesn't do
rats, but other people
do rats with the
following observation--
take a rectangular
room and there
are hiding places in all four
corners that are identical.
While the rat is
watching you put food
in one of these places,
a box cloth over it,
and then you disorient the
rat by spinning it around.
And you watch what the rat does.
And rats are pretty smart.
They do the right thing.
Those opposite corners are
the right answer, right?
Because the room is
rectangular, those
are the two possible places
that the food could be.
So then you can repeat this
experiment with a small child,
you get the same answer, or with
a intelligent adult like me,
and you get the same answer
because it's the right answer.
But now the next thing is
you paint one wall blue
and repeat the experiment.
What do you think the rat does?
Both ways.
You repeat the experiment
with a small child, both ways.
Repeat the experiment with me.
Finally we get it right.
What's the difference?
And when does it happen?
When does this small
child become an adult?
After elaborate and
careful experiments
of the kind that
Spelke is noted for,
she has determined that the
onset of this capability
arises when the child
starts using the words left
and right in their own
descriptions of the world.
They understand left
and right before that,
but this is when they
start using those words.
That's when it happens.
Now we introduce the
notion of verbal shadowing.
So I read to you the Declaration
of Independence or something
else and as I say it,
you say it back to me.
It's sort of like
simultaneous translation,
only it's English to English.
And now you take an adult
human, and even while they're
walking into the room, they're
doing this verbal shadowing.
And what happens in
that circumstance?
That reduces the adult
to the level of a rat.
They can't do it.
And you say, well, didn't
you see the blue wall?
And they'll say, yeah, I saw the
blue wall but couldn't use it.
So Spelke's
interpretation of this
is that the words have
jammed the processor.
That's why we don't use our
laptops in class, right,
because we only have
one language processor,
and it can be jammed.
It's jammed by email.
I'm jammed by used car
salesmen talking fast.
It's easy to jam it.
And when we jam it,
it can't do what
you would think it could do.
So Spelke has an
interpretation to this
that says what we humans have
is combinators, the ability
to take formation of different
kinds and put it together.
I have a different
interpretation,
which I'll tell you
about at the end
if you ask me why I
think Spelke has it--
why I have a different
interpretation from Spelke
for this experiment.
And then what we've got
is we've got the ability
to build descriptions that
seem to be the defining
characteristic of
human intelligence.
We've got it in the
case at Lascaux.
thoughts of Chomsky.
We've got it in these
experiments of Spelke.
We've got descriptions.
And so those are the influences
that led me to this thing
I call the strong
story hypothesis.
And when you think about
it, almost all of education
is about stories.
You know, you start with
fairy tales that keep you
from running away in the mall.
You'll be eaten by big
bad wolf if you do.
And you end up with all
these professional schools
that people go to--
law, business, medicine,
and even engineering.
You might say, well,
engineering, that's not
really-- is that case studies?
And the answer is, if
you talk to somebody
that knows what they're
doing, what they do
is very often telling a story.
My friend, Gerry Sussman,
a computer scientist
whose work I use, is fond
of teaching circuit theory
as a hobby.
And when you hear him
talk about this circuit,
he talks about a signal
coming in from the left
and migrating through
that capacitor
and going into the
base of a transistor
and causing a voltage drop
across the emitter, which
creates a current that
flows into the collector,
and that causes--
he's just basically telling the
story of how that signal flows
through the network.
It's storytelling.
So if you believe
that, then these
are the steps that were
prescribed by Marr and Tomaso
as well in the early days
of their presence at MIT.
These are the things you need to
do if you believe that and want
to do something about it.
And these steps were
articulated at the time,
in part because people in
artificial intelligence
were, in Marr's words,
too mechanistic.
I talked about this
on the first day,
that people would fall in love
with a particular mechanism--
a hammer-- and try to use
it for everything instead
of understanding
what the problem is
before you select the
tools to bring to bear
on producing a solution.
And so being an engineer,
one of the steps here
that I'm particularly
fond of, once you've
got the articulated
behavior 100%,
eventually you have
to build something.
Because as an engineer, I think
I don't really understand it
unless I can build it.
And then building
it, things emerge
that I wouldn't have
thought about if I
hadn't tried to build it.
Well, anyhow, let's see.
Step one, characterize
the behavior.
The behavior has to
story understanding.
So I'm going to
need some stories.
And so I tend to work
with short summaries
of Shakespearean plays,
medical cases, cyber
warfare, classical social
studies, and psychology.
And these stories are
written by us so as
to get through Boris's parser.
So they are carefully prepared.
But they're human readable.
We're not encoding
this stuff up.
This is the sort of
thing you could read,
and if you read that you say,
yeah, this is kind of funny,
but you can understand it.
Summary of Macbeth.
Here is a little fragment of
it, and it is easier to read.
So what do we want to do?
What can we bring to bear
on understanding the story?
If you read that
story, you'd see--
I could ask you a question,
is Duncan dead at the end?
And how would you know?
It doesn't say he's
dead at the end.
He was murdered, but--
I could ask you is this
a story about revenge?
The word revenge
is never mentioned,
and you have to think
about it a little bit.
But you'd probably
conclude in the end
that it's about revenge.
So now we ask ourselves
what kinds of knowledge
is required to know that
Duncan is dead at the end
and that it's about revenge?
Well, first of all, we
need some common sense.
And what we've found,
somewhat to our surprise,
is that much of that can
be expressed in terms
of simple if-then rules.
And these seven rule types
arose because people building
software to understand stories
found that they were necessary.
We knew we needed
the first kind.
If you kill someone,
then they are dead.
Every other one here arose
because we reached an impasse
in our construction of our
story understanding system.
So the may rules.
If I anger you, you may kill me.
Thank god we don't always
kill people who anger us.
But we humans always are
searching for explanations.
So if you kill me, and I've
previously angered you,
and you can't think of any other
reason for why the killing took
place, then the
anger is supposed.
So that's the explanation
for rule type number two.
Sometimes we use abduction.
You might have a firm belief
that anybody who kills somebody
is crazy.
That's abduction.
You're presuming the
antecedent from the presence
of a consequent.
So those are kinds of rules
that work in the background
to deal with the story.
And of course, there
are things that
are explicit in the story too.
Here are some examples
of things that
are-- of causal relations that
are explicit in the story.
The first kind says that this
happens because that happened.
A close, tight
causal connection.
Second kind, we know
there's a causal connection,
but it might be lengthy.
The third kind,
the strangely kind,
arose when one of
my students was
working on Crow creation myths.
He happened to be a
Crow Indian and so
a natural interest
in that mythology.
And what he noted was
that in Crow mythology,
you're often told that
something is connected causally
and also told that you'll
never understand it.
Old Man Coyote
reached into the lake
and pulled up a handful
of mud and made the world,
and you will never
understand how
that happened, is a kind of
typical expression in Crow
creation mythology.
So all of these arose because
we were trying to understand
particular kinds of stories.
OK.
So that's all background.
Here it is in operation.
And that's about the
speed that it goes.
That is reading the story--
the summary of
Macbeth that you saw
on the screen a few moments ago.
But of course, it's
invisible at that scale.
So let me blow a piece of it up.
There you see the piece that
says, oh, Macbeth murdered
Duncan.
Duncan becomes dead.
So the yellow parts are inserted
by background knowledge.
The white parts are
explicit in the story.
So you may have also noted--
no, you wouldn't
have noted-- well,
my drawing attention to it.
We have not only the concept
that the yellow parts--
yes, the yellow parts
there are conclusions.
The white parts are explicit.
And what you can
see, incidentally,
is that-- just from
the colors-- that much
of the understanding
of the story
is inferred from what is there.
It's a funny kind
of way of saying it,
but you've seen
in computer vision
or you will see
that what you think you
see is half hallucination,
and what you think
you see in the story
is also half hallucinated.
It seems that the
authors just tell
us enough to keep us on track.
In any event, we have
not only the yellow parts
that are inferred,
but we also have
the observation that one piece
may be connected to another.
And that can only be
determined by doing
a search through that
so-called elaboration graph.
So here are the same sorts of
things that you can search for.
There's a definition
of a Pyrrhic victory.
You do something or rather you
want something at least you
becoming happy, but
ultimately the same wanting
leads to disaster.
So there it is.
That green thing down there is
reflected in the green elements
up there that are picked
out of the entire graph
because they're connected.
And I'll show you how they're
connected in this one.
So this is the Pyrrhic
victory concept
that has been extracted from
the story by a search program.
So we start with Macbeth
wanting to be king.
He murders Duncan
because of that.
He becomes happy,
because he eventually
ends up being king himself,
but downstream he's harmed.
So it's a kind of
Pyrrhic victory.
And now you say to
me, well, that's
not my definition
of Pyrrhic victory,
and that's OK, because
we all have nuanced
differences in our concepts.
So this is just
one computer's idea
of what a Pyrrhic victory is.
Here are the kinds
of things we've
been able to do as a
consequence of, to our surprise,
just having a suite of rules
and a suite of concepts.
And what I'm going to spend
the next few minutes doing
is just taking you quickly
through a few examples
of these kinds of things.
This is reading Macbeth from
two different cultural points
of view, an Asian point of
view and a US point of view.
There were some
fabulous experiments
conducted in the
'90s in a high school
in the outskirts of Beijing and
in a high school in Wisconsin.
And these experiments involved
having the students read
stories about
violence and observing
the reaction of the
students to those stories.
And what they found was that
at a statistically significant
level, not this or that, but
a statistically significant
level, the Asian students
outside of Beijing
attributed violence
to situations.
And they would ask, what made
that person want to do that?
Whereas the kids in Wisconsin
had a greater tendency to say,
that person must be
completely crazy.
So one attributed to
the situation, the other
was dispositional, to
use the technical term.
So here we see in one
reading of Macbeth--
let me show it blown up.
In the top version,
Macduff kills Macbeth
because there's a revenge
situation that forces it.
And the other interpretation
is because Macduff is crazy.
So another kind of
similar pairing--
oh, wow.
That was fast.
This is a story about the
Estonian Russian cyber
war of 2007.
Could you-- you probably didn't
hear the rules of engagement,
but I don't talk to
the back of laptops.
So if you'd put that
away, I'd appreciate it.
So in 2007, the Estonians
moved a war memorial
from the Soviet era out
of the center of town
to a cemetery in the outskirts.
And about 30% of the Estonian
population is Russian,
and they were irritated by this.
And it had never been
proven, but the next day
the Estonian National
Network went down,
and government
websites were defaced.
And this was hurtful, because
the Estonians pride themselves
in being very
technically advanced.
In Estonia, it's a
right to be educated
on how to use the internet.
They have a national ID card.
They have a law that says if
anybody looks at your data,
they've got to explain why.
They're a very technically
sophisticated country.
And so what's the interpretation
of this attack, which
was presumed to be done
by either ethnic Russians
in Estonia or by
people from Russia?
Well, was it an
aggressive revenge or
was it teaching the
Estonians a lesson?
It depends on what?
It depends on whose
side you're on.
That's the only difference.
And that's what produced the
difference in interpretation
on those two sides--
one being aggressive
revenge and the
other being teaching
the Estonians a lesson.
By the way, I was in
Estonia in January.
That's the statue
that wasn't there.
Give you another example.
I'm just trying to show you
some of the breadth of our story
understanding activity.
So the next example comes
about because shortly
after the terrorist attack
on the World Trade Center,
there was a strong
interest in bringing
political science and
artificial intelligence
together to make it
possible to understand how
other people think when
they're not necessarily crazy,
they've just got
different backgrounds.
The thesis is that we are
the stories in our culture.
So I was at a meeting
in Washington,
and the only thing I
remember from that meeting
is one of the participants
drew a parallel between the Tet
Offensive in Vietnam and
the Arab-Israeli war that
took place about six
or seven years later.
And here's the story.
OK.
And here's what happened
seven years later.
What do you suppose
happened next?
And of course, the
answer is quite clear.
And when we feel like talking
about the long-range eventual
practical uses of the
stuff we're talking about,
this is the kind
of thing we say.
What we want to do is we want
to build for political analysts
tools that would be
as important to them
as spreadsheets are to a
financial analyst, tools that
can enable to predict
or expect or understand
unintended consequence of
actions you might perform.
So this a gap and
alignment problem.
And here is one case
in which we have
departed from modeling humans.
And we did it because
one of our students
was a refugee from
bioengineering.
And he knew a lot about aligning
proteins, sequences, and DNA
sequences.
And so he brought to our group
the Needleman-Wunsch algorithm
for doing alignment.
And we used that to
align those stories.
So there they are
with the gaps in them.
We took those two stories I
showed you on a previous slide.
We put a couple of gaps in.
The Needleman-Wunsch
algorithm aligned them,
and then we were able to fill
in the gaps using one to fill
in the gap in the other.
And since you can't
see it, here's
what it would have filled in.
So that's an example
of how we can
use precedence to think
about what happens next
or what happened in the missing
piece or what led to this.
It's a kind of
analogical reasoning.
My next example is putting
the system in teaching mode.
We have a system.
We have a student.
We want to teach the
student something.
Maybe the student is from Mars
and doesn't know anything.
So this is an example of
how the Genesis system can
watch another version of
itself, not understand the story
and supply the
missing knowledge.
So this is a hint
at how it might be
used in an educational context.
And once you can have a
model of the listener,
then you can also
think about how
you can shape the story so
as to make some aspect of it
more or less believable.
So you notice I'm
carefully avoiding
the word propaganda, which
puts a pejorative spin on it.
But if you're just trying
to teach somebody values,
that's another way
of thinking about it.
So this is the Hansel
and Gretel story.
And the system has been ordered
to make the woodcutter be
likeable, because he does some
good things and bad things.
So when we do that,
you'll note that there
are some things that are
struck out, the stuff in red,
and some things that are
marked in green for emphasis.
And let me blow those
up so you can see them.
So the stuff that the
woodcutter does that's good
are highlighted and
bolded, and the things
that we don't want to
say about the woodcutter
because it makes him look
bad, we strike those out.
And of course,
another way of making
somebody-- what's another way
of making somebody look good?
Make everybody else
look bad, right?
So we can flip a
switch and have him
make comments about
the witch too so
that the woodcutter looks even
better because the bad behavior
of the witch is highlighted.
So these are just some
examples of the kinds
of things we can do.
Here's another one.
This is that Macbeth
story played out in--
it's about 180 80
or 100 sentences,
and we can summarize it.
So we can use our
understanding of the story
to trim away all the stuff that
is not particularly important.
So what is not
particularly important?
Anything that's not
connected to something else
is not particularly important.
Think about it this way.
The only reason
you read a story--
if it's not just for fun-- the
only reason you read a story--
a case study-- is because you
think it'll be useful later.
And it's only useful later
if it exerts constraint.
And it only exerts constraint
if there are connections--
causal connections in this case.
So we take all the stuff
that's not connected,
and we get rid of it.
Then we get rid of
anything that doesn't
lead to a central concept.
So in this case, we say that the
thing is about Pyrrhic victory.
That's the central concept.
We get rid of everything that
doesn't bear on that concept
pattern instantiation.
And then we can squeeze
this thing down to about 20%
of its original size.
And now I come to the thing that
we were talking about before,
and that is how do you
find the right precedent?
Well, if you do a Google
search, it's mostly--
well, they're getting more
and more sophisticated,
but most searches
are mostly keywords.
But now we've got something
better than key words.
We've got concepts.
So what I'm going
to show you now
is a portrayal of an
information retrieval test case
that we did with 14 or
15 conflict stories.
We're interested in how
close they were together.
Because the closer
they are together,
the more one is likely to be a
useful precedent for another.
So in one of these
matrices, what you see
is how close they are when
viewed from the point of view
of key words.
That's the one on the bottom.
The one on the top is how
close they are with respect
to the concepts that
they contain, you know,
the words like revenge,
attack, and not
present in the story as
words, but are present there
anyway as concepts.
And the only point
of this pairing
is to show that the
consideration of similarity
is different depending
on whether you're
thinking in terms of concepts
or thinking in terms of words.
So here's a story.
A young man went to
work for a company.
His boss was pretty mean.
Wouldn't let him
go to conferences.
One day somebody
else in the company
arranged for him to go
to a conference anyhow.
Provided transportation.
He went to the conference, and
he met some interesting people.
But unfortunately,
circumstances were
that he had to leave early
to catch a flight back home.
And then some of the people
he met at the conference
started looking for
him because he was so--
so what story am I telling?
It's pretty obviously a
Cinderella story, right?
But there's no pumpkin.
There's no fairy godmother.
It's just that even
though the agents are
very different in terms
of their descriptions,
the relationships between
them are pretty much the same.
So over the years, what we've
done quite without intending
it or expecting
it or realizing it
is that we have duplicated in
Genesis the kinds of thinking
that Marvin Minsky talks a lot
about in his most recent book,
The Emotion Machine.
He likes to talk in
terms of multiplicities.
We have multiple
ways of thinking.
representations.
And those kinds of reasoning
occur on multiple levels,
from instinctive
reactions at the bottom
to self-conscious
reflection on the top.
So quite without
our intending it,
when we thought about
it one day by accident,
we had this epiphany that
we've been working to implement
much of what is in that book.
So so far, and I'm going to
depart from story understanding
a little bit to talk to you
about some other hypotheses
of mine.
So far, there are two--
the strong story hypothesis
and then there's this
inner language hypothesis
that Chomsky likes
to talk a lot about.
We have an inner language,
and our inner language
came before our outer language.
And this is what makes
it possible to think.
So those are two
hypotheses-- inner language
and strong story.
Here's another
one-- it's important
that we're social animals,
and it's actually important
that we talk to each other.
Once Danny Hillis, a famous
guy, a graduate of ours,
came into my office
and said, have you ever
had the experience of--
well, you often
talked to Marvin.
Yeah, I do.
And have you ever had
the experience, he said,
of having Marvin guess?
He has a very short
attention span, Marvin,
and he'll often guess your
idea before you've fully
explained it?
Yes, I said.
It happens all the time.
Isn't it the case, Danny said,
that the idea that he guesses
you have is better
than the idea you're
actually trying
to tell him about?
Yes.
And then he pointed out, well,
maybe when we talk to ourself,
it's doing the
same kind of thing.
It's accessing ideas and
putting them together
in ways that wouldn't be
possible if we weren't talking.
So it often happens
that ideas come
about when we talk
to each other,
because it forces the rendering
of our thoughts and language.
And if we don't have a friend
or don't happen to have anybody
around we can talk to--
I feel like I talk to
myself all the time.
And maybe that's an
important consequence
or important aspect
of our intelligence
is conversation that we
carry on with ourself.
Be careful doing this out loud.
Some people will think
you've got a screw loose.
But let me let me show
you an experiment I
consider to be extraordinarily
interesting along these lines.
It was done by a friend of mine
at the University Pittsburgh
Michelin.
Mickey, as she is called,
was working with students
on physics problems.
You've all done this
kind of problem,
and it's about pulleys and
weights and forces and stuff.
And so these students
were learning the subject,
and so she gave them a quiz,
and she had them talk out loud
as they were
working on the quiz.
And she kept track
of how many things
the best students
said to themselves
and how many things the worst
students said to themselves.
So in this particular
experiment,
there weren't many students.
I think eight-- four good
ones and four bad ones.
And the good ones scored
twice as high as the bad ones,
and here's the data.
The better students said about
3 and 1/2 times more stuff
to themselves than
the other ones.
So unfortunately,
this is backwards.
We don't know if we
took the bad students
and encouraged them to talk
more, if they'd become smarter.
So we're not saying that.
But it is interesting
observation
that the ones who talked
to themselves more
were actually better at it.
And what they were
saying was a mixture
of problem-solving things
and physics things.
Like I'm stuck or maybe
I should try that again
or physics things like I think
I have to do a force diagram.
A mixture of those
kinds of things.
So talking seems to surface
a kind of capability
that not every animal has.
And then there's this one.
So it isn't just that we
have a perceptual apparatus,
it's that we can direct it
to do stuff in our behalf.
That's what I think
is part of the magic.
So my standard examples--
John kissed Mary.
Did John touch Mary?
Everybody knows that
the answer is yes.
How do you know it?
Because you imagine
it and you see it.
So there's a lot of
talk in AI about how
you gather
common-sense knowledge
and how you can only know
a limited number of facts.
I think it's all
screwy, because I
think a lot of our
common sense comes just
in time by the engagement
of our perceptual apparatus.
So there's John
kissing Mary, and now I
want to give you another puzzle.
And the next puzzle is how
many countries in Africa
does the equator go through?
Does anybody know?
I've asked students who
come to MIT from Africa,
and they don't know.
And some of them
come from countries
that are on the equator
and they don't know.
But now you know.
And what's happened?
Your eyes scan across that
red line, and you count.
Shimon Ullman would call
it a visual routine.
So you're forming-- you're
creating a little program.
Your language
system is demanding
that your visual system
run a little program that
scans across and counts.
And your vision system
reports back the answer.
And that I think is a miracle.
So one more example.
It's a little grizzly.
I hope you don't mind.
So a couple of years ago,
I installed a table saw.
I like to--
I'm an engineer.
I like to build stuff.
I like to make stuff.
And I had a friend of mine
who's a cabinetmaker--
a good cabinetmaker-- helped
me to install the saw.
And he said, you must
never wear gloves
when you operate this tool.
And I said well--
and before I got the first
word out, I knew why.
No one had ever told me.
I had never witnessed
an experience that would
suggest that should be a rule.
But I imagined it.
Can you imagine it?
What I need you to
imagine is that you're
wearing the kind of
fluffy cotton gloves.
Got it now?
And the fluffy cotton glove
gets caught in the blade.
And now you know why
you would never--
I don't think any of you
would ever use gloves
when you operate a table saw
now, because you can imagine
the grisly result. So it's not
just our perceptual apparatus.
It's our ability to deploy
our perceptual apparatus,
and our imagination, I
think, is a great miracle.
That vision is still hard,
as everyone in vision
will tell you.
Some years ago, I was involved
in a DARPA program that
had as its objective recognizing
48 activities, 47 of which
can be performed by humans.
One of them is fly.
So that doesn't count, I guess.
After a couple of years into the
program, they retrenched to 17.
At the end of the
program, they said
if you could do six
reliably, you'll be a hero.
And my team caught
everyone's attention
by saying we wouldn't
recognize any actions that
would distract people.
So vision is very hard.
And then stories do, of
course, come together
with perception, right?
At some point,
you've doubtlessly
in the course of the last
two weeks seen this example.
What am I doing?
AUDIENCE: Drinking.
PATRICK HENRY WINSTON: And
then there's Ullman's cat.
What's it doing?
So my interpretation of this
is that that cat and I are--
it's the same story.
You can imagine
that there's thirst,
that there are activities
that lead to water or liquid
passing into the mouth.
So we give them the same label,
even though visually they're
as different as
anything could be.
You would never get a
deep neural net program
that's been trained
on me to recognize
that that's a cat drinking.
There's visually
nothing similar at all.
All right.
But we might ask this question--
can we have an
intelligent machine
without a perceptual system?
You know, that Genesis system
with Macbeth and all that?
Is it really intelligent
when it doesn't
have any perceptual
apparatus at all?
It can't see anything.
It doesn't know what it
feels like to be stabbed.
I think it's an interesting
philosophical question.
And I'm a little agnostic
on this right now,
a little more agnostic than I
was half a year ago, because I
went back to the republic.
You remember that metaphor
of the cave and the republic?
There's a metaphor of the cave.
You have some prisoners, and
they're chained in this cave,
and there's a fire somewhere.
And all they can see is their
own shadows against the wall.
That's all they've
got for reality.
And so their reality
is extremely limited.
So they're intelligent
but they're limited.
So I think, generalizing
that metaphor,
I think a machine without
a perceptual system
has extraordinarily
limited reality.
And maybe we need a
little bit of perception
to have any kind--
to have what we would be
comfortable to calling
intelligence.
But we don't need much.
And another way of thinking
about it is, sort of the fact
that our own reality is limited.
If you compare our visual
system to that of a bee,
they have a much broader
spectrum of wavelengths
that they can make use of,
because they don't have--
do you know why?
We are limited because we
have water in our eyeballs.
And so some of that stuff
in the far ultraviolet
can't get through.
But bees can see it.
And then that's comparing
us humans with bees.
How about comparing one
human against another?
At this distance, I
can hardly see it.
Can you see it?
AUDIENCE: Boat.
PATRICK HENRY
WINSTON: It's a boat,
but some people can't see it,
because they're colorblind.
So for them, there's a
slight impairment of reality,
just like a computer
without a perceptual system
would have a big
impairment of reality.
So it's been said many times
that what we're doing here
is we're trying to understand
the science side of things.
And we think that that will
lead to engineering advances.
And people often
ask this, and those
who don't believe that human
intelligence is relevant
will say, well, airplanes
don't fly like birds.
What do you think
of that argument?
I think it has a gigantic
hole, and it turns out
that the Wright brothers were
extremely interested in birds,
because they knew that
birds could tell them
something about the
secrets of aerodynamics.
And all flying machines have
to deal with the secrets
of that kind of physics.
So we study humans,
not because we're
going to build a machine
that has neurons in it,
but because we
want to understand
the computational imperatives
that human intelligence can
shed light on.
That's why we think it has
engineering value, even
though we won't in
any likely future
be building computers with
synapses of the kind we have.
Well, now we come to the dangers
that we started out with.
What do you think we should--
suppose that machines can
become--
they do become really smart,
and we've got machine learning.
What is that?
That's modern statistics.
And of course, it's useful.
What if they became really
smart in the same ways
that we're smart?
What would we want to
do to protect ourselves?
Well, for this, I'd like
to introduce the subject
by asking you to read
the following story.
This was part of that Morrison
paying a suite of experiments.
I'm sorry these are
so full of violence.
This happens to be
what they worked with.
So after the students read
this story, they were asked
did Lu kill Sean because
America is individualistic?
And the Asian students would
have a tendency to say yes.
So how can we model
that in our system?
Well, to start out with, this
is the original interpretation
of the story as told.
And if you look at
where that arrow is,
you see that that's where Lu
kills Sean, and just in back
of it is the means.
He shot him with a gun.
But it's not
connected to anything.
And so the instantaneous
response is,
we don't know why
Lu killed Sean.
But what Genesis does
at this point is,
when asked the question,
did Lu kill Sean
because America is
individualistic?
It goes into its
own memory and said
I am modeling an Asian reader.
I believe that America
is individualistic.
I will insert that
into the story.
I will examine the
consequences of that insertion,
and then see what happens.
And this is what happens.
The question is asked and
inserts into the story--
boom, boom, boom.
And now Lu kills Sean is
connected all the way back
to America is individualistic.
And so the machine can
say yes, but that's not
the interesting part.
Now, this is what
it says, but that's
not the interesting part.
The interesting part is this--
it describes to
itself what it's doing
in its own language,
which it treats
as its story of
its own behavior.
So it now has the
capacity to introspect
into what it itself is doing.
I think that's pretty cool.
It's a kind of--
OK.
It's a suitcase word--
self-awareness, consciousness,
a big suitcase word, but you
can say that this system is
aware of its own behavior.
By the way, this is
one of the things
that Turing addressed
in his original paper.
One of the arguments
against AI was--
I forgot what Turing called it--
the disabilities argument.
And people were saying
computers can never
do these kinds of
things, one of which
is be the subject
of its own thought.
But Genesis is now reading
the story of its own behavior
and being the subject
of its own thought.
OK.
So what if they
really become smart?
Now, I will become a little
bit on the whimsical side.
Suppose they really get smart.
What will we want to do?
Maybe we ought to simulate
these suckers first
before we turn them
loose in the world.
Do you agree with that?
After all, simulation is
now a well-developed art.
So we can take these machines--
maybe there will be robots.
Maybe there will
just be programs,
and we can do elaborate
simulations to make sure
that they're not dangerous.
And we would want to do that in
as natural a world as possible.
And we'd want to do these
experiments for a long time
before we turned them loose
to see what kinds of behaviors
were to be expected.
And you see where
I'm going with this?
Maybe we're at it.
I think it's a pretty
interesting possibility.
I'm not sure any of you are it,
but I know that I might be it.
This is a great simulation
to see if we're dangerous.
And I must say, if
we are a simulation
to see if we're dangerous,
it's not going very well.
Key questions revisited.
Why has AI made so
little progress?
Because for too many years, it
was about reasoning instead of
about what's different.
How can we make progress now?
By focusing on what
it is that makes
human intelligence unique.
How can a computer
be really smart
without a perceptual
system or can it be?
And I think yes, but I'm
a little bit agnostic.
Should engineers care?
Absolutely, because
it's not the hardware
that we're trying to replicate.
It's the understanding of the
computational imperatives.
What are the dangers and
what should we do about them?
We need to make any system
that we depend on capable
of explaining itself.
It needs to have
a kind of ability
to explain what it's
doing in our terms.
No.
Don't just tell me
it's a school bus.
Tell me why you think
You did this thing.
You better be able to
defend yourself in something
analogous to a court of law.
These are the things
we need to do.
And finally, my final
slide is this one.
This is just a summary
of the things I've
tried to cover this morning.
And one last thing, I think it
was Cato the Elder who said,
carthago delenda
est. Every speech
to the Roman Senate ended with
Carthage must be destroyed.
He could be talking
about the sewer system,
and the final words would be
Carthage must be destroyed.
Well, here is my analog to
I think this is so,
because I think--
well, many people consider
artificial intelligence
products to be dangerous.
I think understanding
our own intelligence is
essential to the
survival of the species.
We really do need to
understand ourselves better.